what is up can you hear me
yeah man loud and clear all right cool i
just figured i'd come save the show
man god i don't know what the [ __ ]
people are talking about here i don't
know if i can swear
[Laughter]
no i want you to talk real quick about
men being the prize so i think this is a
really
good floor floor is yours man nail it go
for it so this is a concept that a lot
of guys don't understand
um and a lot of it is the disney world
disneyland conditioning
rom-coms all that kind of stuff like be
less so she can become more
you need to shrink so she can become
large uh
women are you know we all know that
women are the protected sex
men are the disposable sex but guys are
being taught from a young age
you know you need to have your wife
happy life
right i'm i'm you know i'm the lucky one
i don't know what she's doing with me
hahaha
and what a lot of people don't
understand especially women
is women are born inherently with value
men must become
okay we talk about this a lot but it's
this idea that
for men to even get on the playing field
they've got to hit a lot of these
different
attraction triggers we talk about the
six sixes right we talk about six feet
tall
six months out of a relationship six
pack abs six figure income
um six inches in the pants right all of
these things
that are the 600 horsepower car 200
horsepower car well i'm still working on
that one
but but in reality you know
women are inherently born with this
value so they
don't know what it's like to have to
work to be attractive right they're just
inherently attractive and they're going
yeah they begin attractive
you know they're always praised for
their beauty from
adolescence like from from the get-go
right
yeah it's and it's it's this thing
that's sold to them where it's
um you are the princess you are the
prize like
don't ever settle for less than your
worth uh
and so what guys really have to
understand
is that once you're able to internalize
that you are the prize and it's you know
you have to
become you have to really earn this
status that we talk about
as far as high value man and once you do
that like
that's when you're going to find real
success but this idea that we have to
shrink so women can become more
and we have to be less so they can be
more um it's just
it's really a lot of nonsense so
guys out there just understand and women
the uncomfortable truth is also women
don't want to be put on this pedestal
like women don't want to feel like
you are worse off than them women want
to feel like you're better than them
right well
if you think about the whole simpling
narrative right what do women do
is they cry on the shoulders of the
friend you know the guy that's in the
friend zone
yeah why are they crying on his shoulder
because some guy
maybe his name's chad maybe his name's
steve mom maybe kevin
could be moff could be any one of those
guys
let her down and alpha widowed her right
did she chase him
yeah did she make every effort possible
yeah did she make him dinner i bet she
did
did she do crazy stuff for him in the
morning i bet she did all that stuff
women want to do stuff for guys that's
when women fall in love with men
actually
i believe is when they're doing things
for men not when men are doing things
for women
women don't fall in love with guys that
are bending over backwards to
take care of them and hang their shelves
and watch their kids while they go salsa
dancing
they don't fall in love with those guys
it's a really interesting test if a guy
can sort of pull that off or if maybe
he's
trying to uh and i know that oh the
internet's gonna go nuts oh like oh why
do we test women oh you're testing women
how dare you like you'd be so glad if a
woman looked at you maf
but it's this idea a couple of even a
couple of days ago
i was doing laundry and i was folding it
and i was like you know what i had a
plate that was coming over later i was
like look you know what
i'm gonna leave it out or i'm gonna
leave some of it in the laundry after
it's done or in the dryer
nice he gets here i see where this is
going i'm gonna say hey look like
help me fold some of this right okay
actually like i'm getting ready to do
something really quick can you can you
you know put this stuff away for me like
there goes on the top drawer that goes
in the middle drawer whatever
yeah and just okay cool and jumped right
at and started like putting my laundry
away
right and there's women out there like
are you kidding me i'm not going to put
your laundry what do i look like i'm not
sure
i'm not going to do that after you yeah
he's like oh yeah totally i'd love to
help and it's like i'm telling you you
got to test these women guys
absolutely you can't just let them have
and let them off the hook man i was like
okay let's let's see what happens let's
see if she's going to step up to the
plate and
and again we're not sitting here saying
limit this fantasy world where we want
things to revert back to the 1950s
but this is part of a larger plan this
is
how is she gonna act like is she going
to add value to your life if you're in
the middle of something and you've got
[ __ ] going on is she going to be a
detriment or is she going to be add
value right is she going to lessen the
burden or is she going to increase it
that's why that's why the white knights
hate us because we get women to come
over and put away our laundry for us
you should be putting the laundry away
for her why don't you go over to her
house and fold her laundry mama a real
man does her laundry a real man does her
flowers
i just want to drop them and say what's
up and just have my two strengths on
that but
i love the new format i love the new
show you know i i couldn't i couldn't
miss on being the on the on the
i couldn't miss out being on the first
episode of the new series so i had to
drop in and say what's up
i bet my boy is going to make a nice
clip out of this for you so you don't
have to read the comments again
yeah yeah well all right man see you all
right
you